この間の講演である質問があったんですね
もう何でもこの人を触ることもできなくて
消毒剤でまで手を洗ったりするんだとかね
それはおそらくもう理屈っぽくて病気でしょうと思いますね
あるいは細菌のことを勉強したと
顕微鏡で細菌なんか見たんだと
あるいはそういう科学的な大学研究者とかね
そういうふうになっちゃって
次ついに感情を忘れて理屈になってしまったと
そこで理屈で考える その机の上っていうのは細菌だらけでしょうね
人の体での細菌だらけでしょうね
人をしゃべる空気っていうのは
また体の中の細菌だらけでしょう
これで細菌だからというふうに人がものすごく病気になってしまっちゃうんです
握手もできなくなっちゃうんですね
人と それはもう理屈だけで言っちゃうと
精神的な病気になってしまう
人は理屈で生きてないので
感情で生きている そこで人間には膨大な感情の世界があるんですね
我々は結婚するにしたっても
子供にしても 仕事にしても
社会にしても 感情があって好き嫌いの感情があって
それで行動する 好きなことをやる
嫌いなことはやめると
その動物も同じなんですね
感情があって それで生きているんですね
じゃあ それから我々は何を推測できますかね
人間の生き方って何だいと
それは全て物が我々見る聞くものが十
五 十じゃなくて 五番目の切なで
あるいは六番目の切なで
眼耳鼻舌身に触れた時なんです
感情を作るのは そうでないと感情は出てこない
ということは 人間が確実に物があると存在しているという状態で生きているんです
バラの花を見て あ これはバラの花だ
これは綺麗だと感情を作る瞬間
そのバラの花が生まれたすぐ目に触れた時だけなんです
ですから 我々の知識体が全部物は存在するんだ
固定しているんだ あるんだという誤解で出来ているんです
もしこの五番目 六番目じゃなくて
十番目 十一番目 きちんと認識するならば
違う認識になるだろうと思いますけど
それは心の法則によって不可能になっている
ですから 実体論というのは心の法則によって普通のものなんです
自我私がいるんだと 世界があるんだと
それは心の法則によってごく普通に現れる誤解なんですね
それで悟りというのは
それはそうじゃないとわかることは
第一番目の悟りなんです
その回転を全く変わっちゃうんですね
そこは一番私が言いたいところはそこら辺にあるんです
アビダンマではなくて
我々の知識が 我々の感情体が
物は存在している時だけ生まれるものだと
それも長い時間 五番目の切なで見たものは十切な間もいるんだから
六番目で見始めたものは九切な間も生きているんだから
そこで七番目の切なで五取見と生まれたら
即行心は生まれません
八番目 九番目 十番目の切なで物を見たら
カルマも生まれません
ということは感情は出てこない
それわからないと思ったら
ものすごい単純な説明できます
例えばペット買ったにしましょう
オウムを買った 大体二十歳ぐらい
ものすごい もっと年間の鳥でしょう
小さい時買ったならば
それ二十歳ぐらい生きているんだから
自分とずっと一緒にいるでしょ
オウムの場合はもうこれおじいちゃんかさっぱりわからないんです
鳥だから いつでも同じ形
まあ唇と足元を見るといくらか年分わかりますけど
歯がないでしょ 生まれつきの
ですからもうほとんど理解しにくい
それで飼っている場合は苦労してないんだから
まあくちばしはぴったしもう鋭くて
舌もあんまり激しく変化しないしね
柔らかいものを食べさせてくれるんだから
走り回ってないんだから
足もそんなに醜くはならないんですね
自分にとってはすごくもう可愛く見える
それでそれ死んじゃったらもうものすごいショックでしょう
10年間も一緒にいたんだから
すごいショックでもうなんかうちにいられなくない
うちに来ると あのもうこんにちはとかなんとか言ってくれるオウムがいないんだから
すごいショック受けちゃうんですね
それでもうどこか行ったところでまた一羽見つかったんだと
見つかってうちに持ってきて
じゃあ面倒見てあげようと思ったんだけど
朝見るともうボケーッと死んでるんだと
そうするとどうします？何のことなく処分するんです
ああ 寂しいとか全然感じないんですね
何の感情もない ああ やっぱり病気になって死ぬ運命でしたとかね
それで終わっちゃうんですね
それどういうことですかね
このオウムと付き合った時間短いんですね
1 日だけと あるいは 20 年間と
だから 20 年間付き合うと
ありとあらゆる感情が生まれる余裕があるんですね
瞬間目に触れたら別にとったことなく
まあわかったと それで終わっちゃうんですね
その働きがそういう この瞬間のチット・ヴィーラの働きでも同じことなんです
ものは目に触れたのは 5番目のセッスナだったら感情が生まれる余裕があるんです
もし 7番目で目に触れたら
もうすぐその見たものは消えちゃいますから
感情生まれません  7番目だったら判断するところまではできます
10番目に触れても判断だけはできます
一応 いいものか悪いものか判断できるところまでだから
これは所縁地と書いているんですね
6つの道を ですから  1 日だけオウムを拾ってきて
買って面倒見ちゃったら
それでも可愛いかないかとかね
何種類かとかね それはわかるでしょうね
それぐらいの判断があるんだけど
なんかなくなったら泣くぐらい感情はないんですね
そういう例えで一応覚えておいてください
じゃあそれから曲所縁に入ります
曲所縁というのは この目に触れる
耳に触れる対象はどんなセッスナででしょうかというと
11番目からなんですね
11番目に目に触れる
それで動揺心が生まれる
で 一応曲所縁の 第1見たら 11番目で動揺心が生まれる
でも有分心 12番目のセッスナで捨
沙檀心が生れる それも有分心
でも残念なことに十七刹那で見たものはもう本当にもうもうもう消える状態なんですね
でしょ？力ないんですね
そこお分かりできるでしょう
力ない 見たものは十七刹那しかないんだから
今十十三刹那 十二刹那で沙檀心が生まれますけど
五蘊陰転生まれるぐらいエネルギーがあの対象は持ってないんです
十三番目だから 十三 十四
十五 十六 十七 死ななくちゃいけないでしょうに
だからあまりも力弱い
見たものがもう死ぬ瞬間で出会った
それでどうなるかというと
沙檀心の次有分心になってしまっちゃうんです
見られなくなっちゃう
心は有分に戻ってしまっちゃう
はっきり言うと こちら沙檀心と書くのはおかしいんですけどね
沙檀心と書いたら 次は必ずしも沙檀にならなくちゃいけないしね
だから五蘊陰転書いたってもいいのにねと私は思いますけど
そういう学派もあると思います
それで六番目まで全部沙檀心で終わっちゃうんです
いわゆる心はちょっと揺れて目が覚めようとするだけ目が覚めません
目が覚めようとしてまた眠ってしまう
だからこれは瞬間によって移動しているだけ
六番目になっちゃうと目が覚めようとするのは六十六の刹那なんですね
ですから沙檀心さえ生まれませんし
五番目の場合は一応沙檀心は生まれますけど
十六刹那で ただ見るとこの順番でお理解できると思います
ですから 六処の場合はものは見てもないんです
目が覚めてない 覚めようとしたんだけど
また眠ってしまう そういうことから
我々に推測できる哲学はそういうことなんですね
仏教ではものは全部生滅変化しているんだと堂々と言ってるんですね
堂々とおっしゃってるんだけど
ものは滅する瞬間見ようとすると見られないんです
見る対象はあまりにも力がないんだから
心が有分心で終わっちゃうんです
簡単に見れるんだったら
みんな一発で悟ってしまっちゃうんです
だからものがある時は見られますけど
消える消えていくなと思って
その間見えません 全然
ということで ものは無常なんですけど
残念ながら人間はそれを知らないんだと
人間が言ってる無常は単なる推測にしか何にもないんです
それはものがある時の知識いっぱい積み重ねて比較して
去年あったものは今日ないんだから
やっぱり無常だとか そう決めるだけ
例えば二重二重共振で全部壊れたでしょうね
それ見て無常を分かったかというと
それは無常に無常を分かったことにならないんですよ
地震が起こる前のものを見て
四十秒ぐらい経ったところで
その時のあるものを見て
昔あったものと比べて全部壊れたんだというだけで
それは正しい無常ではないんです
正しい無常っていうのは
ずっとすべてのものがもう強烈に生滅変化していることなんですね
建物が建物は後で壊れたんだっていうのは
そんな大胆な無常じゃないんです
だから そういうものを見て悟る人はいないんだからね
子供が産んだ母親が自分の子供が死んだことを見て悟るんですかね
悟るところがもっと混乱するだけですから
それでも無常は無常だから
それちゃんと見ると悟るはずなんですけど
やっぱり無常だと執着するもんじゃないかとわかるはずなんです
逆に混乱するだけでしょうし
なんで早く死んだんですかと
ということなんですね
ですから ものはずっと生滅転換している
生滅転換しているんだけど
残念ながら滅の瞬間になってくる
いわゆるもう見たものはもうボロボロ状態になって
もう消えろうとしている
その瞬間だけは認識不可能
そういう風にセットされているんです
プログラムされているんですね
我々の心っていうのは
プログラムされてたって言ったって
そういうプログラムなんです
見るためにはすごいインパクト
強く情報入らなくちゃいけない
あの子供たちに教える時でも
学校で教えるよりは塾で教えたら
子供たちはまあ勉強はしませんだけど
丸暗記ぐらいするでしょう
あれはもう先生もなんかこのあれ
あのあれ あのあれ使わなんていうの
何とですか あの作りてるあの
えっ？えっ？しない？あるでしょ
そういうものをまである
持ってきて 別に子供をぶん殴ることはないんだけど
戦おうではないかとかね
あれですっげえ戦いたり戦ったり
またもうそれでまあそういう風に何か戦争やってるんですね
だからすっごい迫力があって
すごいインパクトがあって
そこでいろんな模擬試験やらせるでしょうに
毎日毎日毎日同じことなんですけど
だから瞬時にすっと見て答える
答えるとかね そういう風にこの機械的にいろんなことをやらせて
あれでみんな頭が悪くなりますからね
ですから 結果はもう全くない
役に立たない連中ばっかりできちゃいますけどね
で まあそれはまあ置いといて
まあそこでなんで学校で丁寧に教えてるのに余裕があって
子供たちの個人的なことまでね
まあ毎日顔を合わせているんだから
親代わりになって教えてるのに
甘えてもらって 先生たちにね
もういろいろ勉強してもらった方が親切に教えてあげます
みんなプロだから うちに行ったっても先生嫌ですよというわけじゃないしね
でもあの学校であれほどインパクト強くやらないでしょ
でてまあ授業だから教えて
子供たちがなんか授業を聞くつもりがないんだったら
何ですか 何かあるんですか？とかね
そこも考えて なんか混乱があったらそれをまた抑えてとか
そういうふうなことですから
塾はそうじゃないんですね
一旦3時に始めたったら
もう3時から2時間だったら2時まで
もう狂別に戦争やってるんだから
子供に他のことを遊ぶとか
そういう全くない あれはすごい強烈でしょうに
それで勉強したような感覚が生まれる
ですから この我々には認識生まれるのは強烈にインパクトが入った時なんですね
柔らかく情報が流れると知らんふりするんですね
電車に乗っても 電車は普通にノーマルに動いているとみんな寝ちゃうんです
電車の中でいろいろトラブルがあったりとか
もう電車が人が誰か まあ夜はよくあることだからね
まあ線路に落ちるとかね
それで一時間二時間電車が止まったりすると
誰も寝てないんですね
寝ればいいのに もう立ってる人はしょうがないんだけど
僕はその時よく見るんですね
この間何回もあったんだから
もう何時間も電車に乗ったまんまで降りることもできない
座ってる連中はものすごい寝ればいいんだけど
一人も寝てない あれは何でしょうかというと
やっぱり情報は強烈でしょうね
心に移る情報が いそうくだでしょうとかね
ああだこうだとかね ですから
普通に電車が動くともう寝ちゃう
あまり情報が激しくないんだから
そういうことで 物事は元気よく存在している瞬間で知っているんであって
元気が消えて死のうと思っている瞬間で知らない
だから我々は知る世界
全てものはある瞬間のみ
ほんの一部しかものの我々は知りません
ですから 我々の知識は正しい真理の知識じゃないんですね
ありのままの知識じゃないんですね
ですから 我々の知識は輪廻転生してくれる
苦しみを作ってくれる
それは修行によって心の回転
このプロセス変えちゃったら無常見られるはずなんです
見られたら まあその輪廻の再会が変わるんだということを言ってるんです
こちらではそれは言わない
これはまあ学生の仏教研究する学生のために書いてる科学的なチャートですからね
まあ今まで説明したのは
この眼耳鼻舌身にものが触れた時なんです
そこで 極大 大所縁 初所縁
極所縁と分けています
それから異聞の場合は
心だけの場合はどのように生まれるかというと二つしかないんです
そこで異聞って何でしょうかというと
心そのものなんですね
心そのものが自分で自己回転して認識するんですね
心は認識機能だから もう外から情報を認識するし
あるいは自分だけで物事を認識しちゃうんですね
で 受分身で心が空いて
そこ受分身が動揺する
そこに受分身が切れる
遮断する それから異聞因天という心が生まれる
いわゆる心が目耳鼻に行かない
外に行かない 中で回転する
異聞因天が生まれる 異聞因天が生まれたら
いきなり即行心が生まれる
いきなり感情が生まれる
そこで可笑縁二つ生まれて
一つの考え方のセットが終わっちゃうんです
あるいは感情だけ生まれて可笑縁生まれないでセット一つが終わる
その二つしかないんです
こちらでは十七摂心の関係はないんですね
別にものを見てるわけじゃないんだから
考えてることだから だから考えてることだから
そのものあってもなくてもどうでもいいでしょ
目で見る場合は 見るものなければ見えませんだから
心には別にものはあってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
回転する まあわかりやすく言えば
例えば一年前で人に会ったことを思い浮かんだと
その瞬間でそれまで全て頭にサッと流れるでしょう
全部流れてしまっちゃう
止まりません だから一年前で
今その人いてもいなくてもどうでもいいんです
今死んでいたっても関係ない
一年前である人に会って
ものすごい楽しかったと
今日思い出すと 同じ感情が生まれるんですね
同じ感情か それよりレベル低い感情か
もっと強烈な感情か どっちかわかりませんだけど
たまにその瞬間より思い出した瞬間で面白いかもしれませんしね
時々感情は強烈になる場合もあるんですね
そういう人とも話したことがあったんだけどね
まあ二人が一緒にいるといろいろ喧嘩とかいろいろあったんだけど
もう別れてもう 2  3年
4年経っちゃうと すごい感情が生まれてしまって
ある人は言ったんですね
なんか冬になってくると靴下を買いてくれたんだ
買ってきて置いてあったんだと
それは奥さんとしてごく普通の当たり前の
もう買い物に行ったらバーゲンであると旦那のもう服を買ったりするんですから
それはもう決まってるんだからね
決して高いものは買わないし
ですからもうそこで冬になってくると
もう大量に冬用の靴下とか売ってるんです
じゃあ男性用のものあったら
そので買って家に入れてあったことで
その時その人は別になんのことなく
その靴下履いてまあ仕事に行ったかもしれませんだけど
その人と別れて何年経ったところで
冬になった時いきなりそれを思い出しちゃったんですね
私ものすごく悲しくなっちゃって
やっぱり冬になってくると
ちゃんと温かい靴下も買いてくれたんですねとか
ものすごく悲しくなって
私に言ったら 私はもうあんた何考えてるんですかと
バカではないかと あなた嫌だと行って出て行った人はもう嫌ですよと
あの人のこときれいさっぱり忘れなさいと言ったんだけど
今更それ言って その人に言ってみてくださいと
さらにあなたのこと嫌われますよ
ですから やっぱりそこでこのこちらの立場から見ちゃうと
やっぱりまあ過去のことを思い出したら
その過去の本当にその出来事が起きた時より強烈な感情が生まれる可能性もあります
だから靴下履いた瞬間でも
あ 温かい靴下でよかったなという感じが生まれたでしょうに
でもその時はそんなに感情生まれた？生まれなかった
ごく普通に受け取った
で  4年  5年経ったところで
すごく涙まで出て 思い出すと
ですから この慰問の働きっていうのは
そういうふうな もう大変怖い働きなんです
ですから ある人に会って楽しかったと
また後でそのことを思い出して怒る可能性もありますね
あの時 あの人はああやったんだけど
結局私を馬鹿にしていたんではないかとかね
私はその時わからなかったんだけどと思っちゃったらすごい怒るでしょうね
ですから慰問というのは
この御門よりはえらいくつきかってなんです
だから我々はもうとてつもなく事実からかけ離れているんです
真理から 決して人間が頭で考えることは大胆なことでも何でもないんです
単なる心の回転だけ だからヴィパッサナー瞑想で妄想と
英語では wandering と
心は走り回っているんだ
英語では 説明しちゃうとね
心の働きが wandering wandering とラベリングされていってるんですね
それだけ wandering
ってのはただ当てもなく
あっちこっちぐるぐるぐるぐるうろうろうろうろ動いてるだけです
あまり価値は入れません
でも俗世間では人間の思考に入れる価値
それこそすごいと思ってるでしょう
何のこともないです 事実見ると
心には何でも想像できますから
実際に人間には角がないでしょうに
でも頭で想像できるでしょ？頭で想像できちゃったらすぐ絵で描けますから
絵で角が生えてる人間の絵を描いたんだからって
人間に角があるんですかね？実際にないでしょう
ですから 実際にないものはいくらでも頭で回転することができる
それまた名画風ですね
なぜならば物質に依存する必要ないでしょ
ですから 即行性はセット全部生まれるんです
確実に即行性は 6つ生まれるんです
7つ 問題は下生えるかないかぐらいのことなんです
ですから 仏教で言ったらこういうこと
人間の身口意の行動の中で一番罪が重いのはどちらの行動かというと考えることなんです
目で物を見て欲が作ったんだから私は汚れたんだと思っても
それはもうはっきり見た時だけ心が汚れるんだって
ちらっと見たら汚れません
汚れる暇がないんだから
でも心の場合は確実に汚れるんです
即行性 7つは確実に生まれる
だから心の中で欲の概念が生まれたら
確実に即行性 7つ生まれるんです
心に汚れがない人はちらっと綺麗なものに立っても
別にもう気にしないことはいくらでもあります
ですから 淫は危ない 身口意の中で意は一番罪深い
意でする罪が確実に完全なんです
体でする罪はもう完全にほとんどならない
例えば 私は人を殺そうとしてぶん殴ったんだけど
力がなかったと あいつはもっと力強かったと言うと
もう殺せないでしょうに
だから成立しないんですね
罪が でも殺したいという気持ちは完璧にできてるんだから
その罪がもう完璧にできてるんです
体で行動はもう完成する
完成することは不可能
例えば人を騙したいと思ったと
それで意の罪はもうやってるんだ
もう完璧終わり それから実行でしょうね
それで私はいろいろ工夫して嘘をつく
嘘ついても向こうは全然信じないと
バレちゃったと 私は嘘つくの下手で
そうすると嘘をつくという口のカルマが成立してないんです
私は嘘を言ったんだけど
向こう側は騙されなかったと
嘘という口の行為は成立していない
でも意の行為はもうとっくにできてるんです
ですから 淫は一番罪深くて
一番気をつけるべきですよと
心は一番気をつけるべきですよというのが仏教の教え
ジャイナ教は逆で体の行為は一番恐ろしいんだと言ってるんですけど
仏教はそれに笑っちゃうんです
で バカな人の立場から見れば
銀行強盗でもできればいいなと思うのは
もうなんか可愛いと思っちゃうでしょうね
でも銀行強盗しちゃったら
こういう恐ろしい人だと思っちゃうでしょ
仏教は逆なんです なんか面白いことやりたくて銀行強盗やったって
それはそんなに大したもんじゃなくて
本当にその人の考え方をもっと気をつけろと
ですから 子供たちでも何か悪いこと
なんでやったの？なんか面白いだからやったよとか言ったら
別にそれはそんなに大した問題じゃないんですね
でも社会に対して怒りがあって
両親に対して怒りがあって
もう学校に対してすごい怒りがあって
なんとかもうやるぞと思ってやっちゃう
そこはすごい問題なんですね
俗世間から見れば 実際に銀行強盗を起こしたことだけが事件であって
生徒が刃物で先生を殺したんだと
それでこれすごい事件だと思って
それだけあつくて テレビでも 4時間ぐらいいろんなスペシャル番組やって
でも何も言ってない 何も考察
何もない ただ時間を作っとって金儲けただけ
ここで人が死んでるんだけど
ある人がそれですごい金儲けてるんです
だからそれに私は腹が立ちますけど
でも問題は子供が生徒を刺したその事件じゃないんですね
そこまでのこの子供の心の思考過程なんですね
それを見ると ほとんどの子供っていうのはお互いに影響あるんだから
同じ思考過程を持ってるんですね
たまたま一人の子供が実行しただけで
だから問題はその思うほど小さくはないんです
あのアイスバーグですか
この氷の山 ですから その上にあるちょっとほんのしっちょっとなアイス
氷しか見えませんだけど
巨大な氷は下にあるんですから
軽く見てはいけないんですね
だからその子はある日突然先生殺したんじゃなくて
小さい時からも 生まれた時からは自分の考え方
いろんなものによって変化して変化して変化していって
そこまで進んだんですね
お巡りさんのピストルを盗もうとした子供も同じことで
ピストル見た瞬時に子供だから
あ あれ面白そう 取ろうと
そういう子供の可愛らしい行動じゃないでしょ
あれは ちっちゃな子供だったらなんか面白いこと
なんかすぐ手が伸びて
それ捕まってるでしょうに
赤ちゃんもそうでしょうに
たまにお母さんたち お母さん抱っこして後ろで持って連れて行っちゃうと
まあ隣の全然関係ない人であろうとも
なんか面白いもの 首にでもかけていたら
そんな子供何のことなく手を出してそれ取ったりするでしょうに
それはただ可愛い行動だけだ
面白いんだから 他のおばあちゃんの首に掛けてたマフラーかもしれませんだけど
子供がそれなんか気に入っちゃったら
赤ちゃんがそれ必ず取る
あれは泥棒でもなんでもない
それでお母さん知らなくたって
後ろの人 誰が自分の首を引っ張ってるかと言えば
赤ちゃんだから それは丁寧にそれ外してもらって行きますからね
それは問題じゃないんだけど
そういう可愛らしい行動じゃないんですね
たまたまお巡りさんがピストル持ってるのを見て面白いんだから取ろうということではなくて
長い間ある思考を心の中で回転させて
回転させて回転させて
そういう結果になったんだからね
だからそこはものすごい大事に考えて
もし社会をね なんとか子供たちを救ってあげたいと思うならば
その関係の方々はそれを考えなくちゃいけないんですね
それは考えない 今の子供は戦争ゲーム好きだからとかね
でもそれ実際にやろうと思うバカがないんですよ
それで終わっちゃうんです
そうじゃなくて 戦争ゲーム作ったことも問題であって
それから本物の思考を作ったこの子にもまた問題であって
何でも本物の思考でしょうし
本物でなきゃいけませんよと
だから子供は別に子供本物好きになるのは当たり前でしょうに
そういう風にこの一番問題は人間の意の働き
意で思うものは全部完全にカルマになっちゃうんです
だから我々面白おかしく思っちゃうでしょ
あいつは死んでしまってもいいんじゃないかだこうだとか
それは全部完璧にカルマになっちゃうんです
遊びじゃないんです 心の妄想って
我々思うほど面白くないんです
輪廻っていうのは ものすごい怖い
恐ろしいものなんです
思っただけだからいいんじゃないかと
冗談じゃないんです 思ったことが問題ですと
[背景音楽]だから人間の心をね
まあちょっと開けてみると
どれぐらい醜い考え方やら
汚い考え方やら 恐ろしい考え方やら
どれほどあるかと キリがないでしょう
ほとんどの文化では このポルノですか
ポルノグラフィック関係の文学やらね
その全て断っているのも
やっぱりよく考えてなんです
良くないんだ それは完全に頭の中で考えるものなんです
妄想するものなんです
じゃあ頭の中で考えることだからいいんじゃないかと
危険がないんだからって
そうじゃないんです 頭で考えるたびに
もう完全にカルマは終わってるんです
意のカルマが ただ 体でやってないかもしれません
でも たまに人々は体でもそれをやろうとする
今最近 この人殺したことを問題にするんだけど
十人の青年たちが女の子を二人捕まえて暴行を起こしたんだけど
それは全然扱わないんですね
あれ何ですかと 私はわからないんだけど
ある生徒を先生殺したんだから
これすごいすごいと思うけど
また赤また赤あだ子だとか
今のキレる子供たちの問題とかね
子供がキレるのは今だけじゃないんだからね
大人もキレるし だからまあしょうがないしまあ
で 子供たちに聞くとすぐキレちゃうんですね
それで包丁というか 刃物持ってるのは中学生だけじゃないでしょうに
小学生持ってるんだから
その時にそれを何とかしてね
もう考え方変えてあげないと
大きくなったらもうコントロールできなくなっちゃう
ですから まあこの性的なことにしたっても
それはまあ それは別にあまり気にしない
あれも十人の青年たちでしょうに
それはあってはならないことであるし
自分がもう未熟でまだ大人になってないっていうことはちゃんと自覚してほしいし
それでいろんな情報やら文学というんですか
リテラチャーと英語ではね
いろんなそういう性的なもうあだこだとか見たり見たり聞いたり
あだこでやったりして
それで実行しようとする
それでまた社会で別に問題に扱わない
問題と そういうことで
まあそれは仏教の立場を説明したかっただけなんですけど
仏教の心理学の世界では
心で思うと もうもう完全にカルマになってしまう
だからこの表のこの氷の山の上だけ見て生きていると問題ばっかりなんですね
夫婦は別れたんだと ああいうことで
そうじゃなくて 初めからもうこの思考の何か間違いがあったんです
相手をなんかどこかで貶すとか
バカにするとか否定するとかあって
それは口では言わないんだけど
どんどんそれを大きくなって大きくなって行動に移しただけ
行動に移した部分はほんのわずかだけなんです
じゃあ離婚しましょうということは
でも何年間も毎日毎日もう何時間も怒りの概念が回転したでしょうに
ですから 育てるのは意であって
眼耳鼻舌身別にもうちょっと気をつけただけでいいんです
目でいろんなものを見ると
すごい心が乱れて欲が生まれるというのは
見なきゃいいでしょうに
それだったら いろんな音が入っちゃうと頭がおかしくなって悪いことをしたくなりそうで
聞かなかったらそれで終わりでしょうね
でも心はそうじゃないでしょ
心は育てなくちゃいけない
ですから 修行は眼耳鼻舌身になし
コントロールすればいい
見なきゃいい お釈迦様簡単に簡単にそれ言うんです
それは戒律に入れてるんです
眼耳鼻舌身のコントロールすることは戒律に入れる
戒律っていうのは最も簡単なことだから
目を気をつけろ 目でものを見ると欲と怒りが生まれないように気をつけろ
それだけ 音を聞くと欲と怒りが生まれないように気をつけてください
それは戒律 意の場合はそこはうまくいかない
ですから もうすごく長い時間
ものすごい丁寧に意の回転をもういい方向へ行くようにしなくちゃいけない
この慈悲の瞑想は一つの手段なんですね
一人で何を妄想するかというと
全部罪ばっかりでしょうに
それだったらとことんその代わりに妄想したければ慈しみの妄想でもしてみなさいと
それは全部善行為だから
そうすると その人の行動でも素晴らしい行動になるんです
ですから 瞑想の場合は欠かせない
もう確実にやらねばならない瞑想を通して慈しみという概念を入れているんです
それは好きでも嫌いでもなく
幸福でありますようにという感じなんですね
生命を 愛想は好きですよ
愛想は嫌いですよという感情じゃなくて
関係ないんだと私にとっては
私の好き嫌いは単なる罪だけですと
好きは欲で嫌いは怒りで
だからゴキブリは嫌いだ
だからゴキブリには慈悲の瞑想しないという瞑想にならないんですね
カラスは嫌いだからカラスには慈悲の瞑想しません
その代わりに探鳥するのは慈悲の瞑想します
何の意味もないんですね
私の好き嫌いは完璧に罪